[Musique]
les orientations budgétaires 2023 du
département ont été élaborés de façon à
maintenir le haut niveau d'action
départementale sur le territoire en
préservant autant que possible les
Réunionnais des nouvelles contraintes
économiques annoncées pour l'an prochain
pour ce faire la collectivité peut
s'appuyer sur une situation financière
saine afin 2022 fruits d'un travail de
co-construction par les élus et les
cadres du département ces orientations
budgétaires ont été planifiées sur la
base du plan de mandature voulu évolutif
[Musique]
le Département souhaite poursuivre en
2023 la démarche d'aller vers en
formalisant notamment des forums
territorialisés qui réuniront l'ensemble
des acteurs et proposeront une offre de
service complète sur le plan de
l'insertion fort du succès de la
caravane d'accès aux droits lancés en
2022 la collectivité poursuivra son
déploiement en augmentant la couverture
territoriale et les fréquences de
passage gagnant proximité c'est aussi
être mobilisé auprès des ménages en
difficulté notamment se frapper par des
problèmes d'impayés de loyer et
améliorer la réponse sociale pour ces
familles
la culture elle aussi doit se rapprocher
des publics ainsi la collectivité
augmentera en 2023 l'offre culturelle en
tâchant de mieux la répartir sur le
territoire
[Musique]
la politique volontariste du département
concernant l'accompagnement des usagers
sera accentué en 2023 il s'agira dans un
premier temps de poursuivre la
modernisation des espaces d'accueil dans
les maisons départementales en intégrant
davantage de maison dans le plan initié
en 2022 pour permettre locataire de
devenir propriétaire de leur logement
cette année le département favorisera le
parcours résidentiel encourageant ainsi
la réussite sociale et l'épanouissement
des ménages nos aînés ainsi que les
personnes vivant avec un handicap n'ont
pas été oubliés dans ses orientations
budgétaires le département a en effet
pour objectif de faciliter le parcours
de vie de ses publics en perte
d'autonomie selon l'évolution de leur
projet personnalisés d'une manière plus
globale notre ambition est de développer
des démarches centré usagées dans nos
projets pour optimiser nos processus et
satisfaire ainsi la demande du public
[Musique]
les crises sanitaires et économiques et
les pénuries qui en ont découlées ont
montré ces dernières années combien
notre territoire est encore trop
dépendant soucieux de soutenir
l'agriculture réunionnaise et ses
acteurs et dans le but de limiter
l'impact de ces crises sur la qualité et
le coût de la vie de la population
réunionnaise le département poursuivra
en 2023 son action en faveur de la
souveraineté alimentaire de l'île pour
relever ses défis la collectivité
poursuivra la mise en oeuvre du plan
ambitieux agrippé 2030 en apportant son
soutien aux productions de
diversification pour valoriser la
production locale un soutien sera
apporté à la mise en place d'unités de
transformation ou encore à
l'organisation de salon nouveau ou
redimensionné
la promotion de la production locale se
joue également dans les assiettes de nos
jeunes la collectivité souhaite à
travers la restauration scolaire un
ancrage territorial pour relever les
défis de la souveraineté alimentaire le
département soit également développer
une coopération à l'échelle indien
océanique enfin chef de fil dans le
domaine de la gestion de l'eau la
collectivité poursuivra son action
structurante afin d'étendre l'irrigation
du foncier agricole en 2023
[Musique]
le développement de notre territoire
contribue à la création de richesses
locales et à la préservation de la
qualité de vie des Réunionnais la
collectivité aménage ces territoires
notamment à travers des équipements
touristiques et l'accompagnement de
porteurs de projets dans les hauts pour
rééquilibrer le territoire en équipement
structurant elle poursuivra en 2023 le
déploiement et le pilotage du pacte de
solidarité territoriale deuxième
génération dans une logique de
désenclavagement du territoire
l'amélioration des déplacements sur le
réseau routier demeurent une priorité
tout comme la sécurisation des routes
départementales
la préservation de nos espaces naturels
sensibles et de notre biodiversité
constitue également un pan de
l'aménagement du territoire cela
continuera de se concrétiser par des
actions de reboisement et de lutte
contre les espèces exotiques et
envahissantes
[Musique]
pour réussir le plan de mandature il
nous faut développer notre agilité notre
vélo cité et notre réactivité cela
passera en 2023 par l'élaboration d'un
plan de transformation numérique pour
simplifier et mieux suivre les démarches
des usagers ainsi que par un plan de
formation de nos agents mais aussi par
l'expérimentation au sein du laboratoire
d'innovation publique dont la mise en
place se poursuit si moderniser l'action
publique suppose une meilleure
organisation de nos méthodes de travail
en interne cela implique aussi une
volonté de communiquer avec transparence
sur nos projets et nos actions en
informant le public en temps réel sur
nos différents sites internet plus
globalement l'objectif se résume à
inclure davantage les Réunionnais dans
nos politiques publiques dans la prise
de décision le budget d'initiative
citoyenne en est un bon exemple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]